fue violada una noche de octubre de 2016
mientras volvía a casa del trabajo un
taxista se ofreció a llevarla le dijo lo
inseguro que puede ser para una mujer
joven estar sola por la calle en la
noche en ese momento Karina solo tenía
19 años se sintió vulnerable él parecía
agradable subió al coche y su vida
cambió para siempre
era un taxista era tarde la noche no
debería haber subido yo era joven y
debería haberlo sabido
todo este tiempo me decía que debería
haberlo visto venir pensé que nadie me
creería si todo el mundo lo veía
Y esa es la sensación que más se me
queda cada año se registran 94.000
violaciones o intentos de violación en
Francia pero solo una de cada diez
mujeres presenta denuncia Karin estuvo
en estado de shock durante tres días
antes de decidirse acudir a la policía
aquí estamos frente a la comisaría donde
finalmente pude presentar cargos ese día
tuve que ir a tres comisarías diferentes
en la primera me sacaron literalmente a
empujones y cuando al final pude
presentar cargos no pasó nada
sin embargo el agresor ya era conocido
por la policía ya había sido condenado a
un año de prisión por agresión sexual
cuando su violador volvió a atacar a
otra víctima 10 días después el fiscal
abrió finalmente una investigación seis
años después se le impuso una condena de
4 años de prisión suspendida y dos años
de la llamada detención alternativa con
un rastreador electrónico lo que
significa que ese mismo día pudo salir
el libre del juzgado
[Música]
con esta sentencia de 4 años de prisión
suspendida y dos años de detención
alternativa sentimos que el tribunal
Había decidido a propósito que este
hombre no pasara ni un día en prisión
porque tiene un trabajo es empresario
porque ponerlo en detención habría
[__] su tratamiento psiquiátrico
que había comenzado años antes y también
porque las cárceles aquí están llenas
los estudios más recientes muestran que
en Francia sólo seis de cada mil
agresores declarados culpables ante un
tribunal Karin que ahora tiene 25 años
sigue luchando por la justicia y espera
un resultado diferente en un segundo
juicio que no tendrá lugar antes de 2024